looking at the numbers for us it looks
adele certainly when you look at all the
regional
numbers as well that it's good news it
appears that the virus is
shrinking
yeah an improved picture we're heading
in the right direction i would
is is my take from this but so it has
changed
but and there is a big but it's only
slightly
uh so it would suggest uh that while the
picture is improving
uh there is a question over how fast it
is improving
so just to compare the rate with last
week
last week it was between uh 0.7
and 1.1 this week it's between 0.7
and 1 so a slight drop in the upper
range
of that estimated r number and what that
figure means is that on average
for every 10 people infected with
covid19 they will go on to infect
between
7 and 10 other people the growth rate
has also improved um somewhat in that
uh it's between minus five percent and
two percent
minus two percent which means that it
suggests that the
uh are that the infection numbers are
shrinking by between two
and five percent every day so as you say
this looks to be overall a good picture
an improved picture
especially when you consider what the
situation was say a month ago
but the infection rate is still high
perhaps it isn't falling
as as fast as the government and as the
scientists
uh hope when you look at the range as
well uh the regional variations
um it's it's a positive picture actually
it's the first time in weeks that we've
seen
uh the upper range of the r number four
all of the regions to be one
or below and similar for the growth rate
it's the first time in weeks that the
growth rate
has been zero or below um the
region that looks like it has the uh
higher
our number out of all of the regions is
the northeastern yorkshire that's
between 0.8
uh and one um compare that to london
for example where it's estimated to be
between 0.6
and 0.8 so there's not a lot in it